vorstoss vom außenminister geimpfte
sollen früher als andere ins restaurant
oder kino dürfen fordert heiko maas als
erster bundesminister rückkehr nach
russland der kremlkritiker navalny ist
in moskau gelandet anhänger werden
festgenommen
was mittlerweile passiert unklar und
spitzen fahrt im eiskanal natalie
geisenberger feiert in oberhof ihren 50
weltcup erfolg
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster herzlich willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten am sonntag
norbert lehmann ist auch damit viel
wintersport und showprogramm am dienstag
wollen bund und länder klären wie es
weitergeht in der korona krise welche
einschränkungen wegfallen bleiben oder
noch verschärft werden heute aber sorgt
der außenminister für aufregung beim
thema heiko maas plädiert anders als die
regierung dafür geimpften früher den
besuch von restaurant und kino zu
erlauben und bekommt heftigen
widerspruch
britta spiekermann soll es sonderrechte
geben für geimpfte die debatte darüber
ist kontroversen schon länger im gange
heute nun ein vorstoß aus ungewohnter
ecke der außenminister mischt sich ein
heiko maas findet es geht nicht um
privilegien sondern um die ausübung von
grundrechten von geimpften 1 günster
nimmt niemanden mehr an beatmungsgerät
weg damit fällt mindestens ein zentraler
grund für die einschränkung der
grundrechte weg das
bundesgesundheitsministerium hält nichts
von dieser idee hält nichts vom mehr
freiheiten für geimpfte schließlich sei
nicht klar ob diese noch ansteckend sein
bis dahin keine ausnahmen die debatte
schwelt weiter doch zunehmend richten
sich die augen auf kommenden dienstag
bund länder treffen hinter ruhigen
kulissen jede menge unruhe hohe todes
und infektionszahlen angstraum mutation
kommt es zum noch härteren shutdown
unter umständen sind härtere maßnahmen
jetzt auch volkswirtschaftlich sehr viel
günstiger wenn es nämlich gelingt dann
zügiger wieder zur normalität
zurückzukehren weitere freiheits
einschränkungen gegen druck kommt von
den liberalen sie fordern eine
sondersitzung des bundestags auch am
dienstag wenn es aus sicht der
bundesregierung ein neues risiko gibt
dann erwarten wir dass die regierung im
parlament da legt auf welcher
datengrundlage auf welchen
wissenschaftlichen fakten sie ihre
meinung gebildet hat
es ist davon auszugehen dass die
regierung die daten lage als
besorgniserregend interpretiert am
dienstag die entscheidung darüber ob es
etwa nächtliche ausgangssperren geben
wird oder home office pflicht es wären
die härtesten maßnahmen seit beginn der
pandemie
die deutsche bahn prüft offenbar ob sie
in ihren zügen das tragen von fft zwei
masken zur pflicht macht einem
medienbericht zufolge habe der konzern
bereits zehn millionen solcher masken
bestellt bayern setzt ab morgen bereits
auf eine ffp zwei masken pflicht in
bussen und bahnen sowie beim einkaufen
herkömmlichem und nase bedeckungen
reichen dann nicht mehr in österreich
hat sich die neue besonders ansteckende
virus variante schon relativ stark
verbreitet daher verlängert das land
seinen corona shutdown und zwei wochen
frühestens am 8 februar sollen geschäfte
und museen wieder öffnen allerdings
unter strengen auflagen
künftig gilt eine ffp zwei masken
pflicht in öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln
und supermärkten und der mindestabstand
zwischen menschen wird auf zwei meter
ausgedehnt
nach russland dort ist vor knapp einer
stunde der kremlkritiker alexej nawalny
gelandet freiwillig ist in seine heimat
zurückgekehrt trotz dieser vorgeschichte
es war im vergangenen august navalny
verliert auf einem inlandsflug das
bewusstsein aktivisten bringe ihnen zur
behandlung nach deutschland dort wird in
seinem körper das nervengift novikov
nachgewiesen
nach wochenlangem koma kommt nadal
wieder auf die beine und beschuldigt
direkt präsident putin seine rückkehr
jetzt ein wagnis mit offenem ende
axel sturm
flughafen moskau flog wo am abend
sicherheitskräfte gehen massiv gegen
dabei die anhänger vor rund 20 menschen
werden verhaftet
es gibt barrikaden journalisten dürfen
nicht ins terminal der russische staat
zeigt die harte hand man will keine
öffentliche unterstützung für russlands
top oppositionellen
ich bin aus demselben grund hier wie die
meisten um alexej zu begrüßen und dann
macht der staat das was niemand hier in
luckow geahnt hat sie fliegen alexej
nawalny an einen anderen flughafen und
alle unterstützer und journalisten
stehen am falschen ort der navalny
thriller geht in die nächste runde
der berliner patient wie in staatschef
putin entkamen beim abflug in berlin
kaum zu seinem sitzplatz so viele
journalisten waren an bord
was für ein flug ich möchte mich bei
deutschland bedanken ich möchte mich bei
ihnen bedanken
ich hoffe wir kommen alle heil an alexei
navalny den nerven giftanschlag hat er
überlebt jetzt droht ihm zu hause eine
lange haftstrafe
sie werfen ihm einen verstoß gegen
bewährungsauflagen vor und ermitteln in
einem neuen verfahren wegen
unterschlagung
da war nichts rückkehr ist riskant aber
die kreml linie ebenfalls niemand will
aus hawaii nie ein opfer machen obgleich
man es im grunde genommen bereits getan
hat zur stunde ist nicht klar ob navalny
nach seiner ankunft festgenommen worden
ist der thriller geht weiter
dafür begann auch sie stehen ja am
falschen flughafen was passiert jetzt
weiter mittlerweile nehmen ja wir sind
hier zwar am falschen ort aber wir
hatten einen kamera kollegen mit
geschickt mit dem flugzeug von dabei und
er hat berichtet dass nach der landung
zunächst alle passagiere inklusive dem
oppositionellen mit dem flughafen bus
zum terminal gebracht wurden und dort
hat alexej nawalny eine kurze ein kurzes
statement abgegeben hat gesagt er sei
sehr froh wieder zurück in der heimat zu
sein und er habe keine angst die anderen
menschen sollten auch keine angst haben
dann weiter an der passkontrolle
erscheint es jetzt aber doch so dass
alexej nawalny aufgefordert wurde sich
auf ein polizeirevier zu begeben
jetzt wird man abwarten müssen ob das
sich um ein paar stunden handel das dem
oppositionellen dort quasi noch einmal
die neuen vorwürfe erklärt werden die
gegen ihn im raum stehen oder aber
direkt in haft kommt und tatsächlich
erst am 29 januar dann zusammen
gerichtstermin wieder erscheint vielen
dank für begann sie bleiben für uns auf
den spuren von alexei navalny in
afghanistan haben bewaffnete angreifer
zwei richterinnen auf offener straße
erschossen
die beiden frauen waren auf dem weg zur
arbeit am obersten gericht präsident gar
nie macht die radikalislamische taliban
verantwortlich
trotz laufender friedensverhandlungen
zwischen der terror miliz und der
afghanischen regierung gibt es immer
wieder angriffe und gezielte attentate
zurück nach deutschland das heute fast
flächendeckend eine winterlandschaft war
in ostfriesland beispielsweise dichtes
schneetreiben rund um den berühmten
pilsum leuchtturm eine traumhafte
kulisse empfingen die spezies
spaziergänger auf dem fichtelberg in
sachsen
außerdem konnte man im eis nebel einen
halo beobachten einen lichthof um die
sonne in dem sich die spektralfarben
zeigen
wunderschön zum wintersport da war die
deutsche rennrodlerin natalie
geisenberger besonders erfolgreichen
arbeit des endlich dieser sprichwörtlich
berühmte knoten geplatzt nach der
rückkehr aus der babypause acht zweite
plätze in acht cee sorgen heute oberhof
wieder ein sieg übrigens ihr 50 im
rodel-weltcup
na endlich sie kann es noch natalie
geisenberger ist nach fast zwei jahren
wieder auf der siegerstraße
rechtzeitig vor der heim wm am königssee
ende januar zeigt sich die
olympiasiegerin in west form eher zur
nebensache wird das jubiläum hauptsache
platz eins im thüringer eiskanal vor der
österreicherin madeleine eckel einer der
reiter aus berchtesgaden wird dritter
und es gab heute noch weitere deutsche
erfolge im wintersport besonders
spannend machten es die nordischen
kombinierer in val di ferne
eric frenzel links als zweiter und
vinzenz geiger rechts als dritter haben
einen einzelsieg kaufte und verpasst in
spektakulären zielsprint ist der
norweger magnus rieber unten mal wieder
der schnellste sein vierter saisonsieg
treffsicher franziska preuß wird beim
weltcup in oberhof zweite die französin
julie asimo gewinnt den zwölf einhalb
kilometer massenstart dritte wird die
schwedin hanna ölberg francesco
friedrich schreibt weiter popgeschichte
nach seinem sieg im zweier gestern in st
moritz gewinnt er heute auch die
viererbob konkurrenz und feiert damit
seinen 48 weltcup-sieg das hat noch
keiner vor ihm geschafft
im ersten sonntagsspiel der fußball
bundesliga besiegt bayern freiburg mit 2
1 die münchner bauen damit ihre
tabellenführung auf vier punkte vor
leipzig aus und sind damit bereits
hinrundenmeister freiburg ist achter das
handball wm vorrundenspiel deutschland
gegen kap verde ist wegen corona für
einem afrikanischen team abgesagt und
als sieg für deutschland gewertet worden
der dfb reagierte erleichtert ich bin
riesig froh natürlich als spieler hier
ist jetzt weil wir einfach dass die
unsicherheit beseitigen konnten die
spieler wissen jetzt dass es sich auf
das spiel gegen ungarn vorbereiten
können das war von vornherein zu
erwarten dass das alles entscheidende
spiel um den vorrundensieg sein wird
unter spiele gegen ungarn dienstagabend
live bei uns im zdf ab 20 15 und wir
werfen zum schluss noch ein blick aufs
wetter in der neuen woche da regnet oder
schneit es von schleswig holstein über
sachsen bis nach bayern
sonst dichte wolken die temperaturen
null bis sechs grad
das war es von uns für den moment danke
für ihr interesse
mehr gibt es im heute journal mit
christian sievers um drei viertel zu